joe just
talk about how your offense is just
looks like it's falling apart on third
down
well
you got to look at those third downs i
mean there's a lot of third and longs
we're just not playing good football
joe flacco after last night's game and
look i think that the broncos went into
the contest with the game plan that they
needed offensively long drives run the
ball
tire out the chief's defense the chief's
defense had given up 180 rushing yards
or more for four straight games they got
a touchdown uh yeah the chief scored the
next 10 points and then it was 13 to 6
after the mahomes injury but i feel like
after the mahomes injury because look
after the injury it was first and goal
and matt moore was putrid in those three
opportunities to score a touchdown i
think the broncos thought i forget about
the game plan we can just throw the ball
and we're going to win this game 27 to
13 or 24 to 13 or something like that
first play flacco gets sacked loses the
ball chief score touchdown it's 20 to
six and i felt like they just decided
throw the ball throw the ball through
them but the only problem is they
couldn't block for joe flacco he can't
get away from pressure when the pocket
collapses and he had too many guys
dropping passes it was just a nightmare
once they decided to abandon the run and
focus on throwing the ball big cat see i
i don't even think it was a game plan
thing i think the i think the broncos
offense is just horrific just absolutely
horrific troy aikman said it during the
broadcast he said this might be one of
the worst offenses i've ever watched
they were one in 13 on third down so yes
joe flacco you have a problem on third
down and i just i don't understand
what the idea was going into this season
this was one of those things where when
they traded for joe flacco everyone
everyone to a person like from the
smartest analyst to the most casual fan
said what is going on here why do we
think joe flacco is going to you know
reinvigorate your offense put some life
into this unit
it's just not there it's not there he's
entering his crime
he's entering his prime john elway said
he's entering his prime it's crazy to
watch and and credit to the chiefs
defense because they played a heck of a
game and i think there's always
something to be said for having a star
player get injured and having everyone
else step up and the chiefs defense
being like hey you know what we don't
have patrick mahomes to bail us out of
this one we got to make some plays
ourselves but
the broncos i do not understand what
john elway is doing i actually think
mike did you see before the game peyton
manning in his orange sweater standing
on the sideline talking to troy aikman
that's your future denver if you want
and i'm not talking about playing
quarterback i'm talking about being the
president of football ops and and
heading up the entire operation because
this john elway thing since they've won
the super bowl and of course they won a
super bowl so you gotta mention it it
has been real real bad i think they're
like 13 and 27 or some some ridiculous
record and this is a franchise mike that
you know all too well
they don't miss the playoffs three years
in a row they don't miss you know they
don't go under 500 three years in a row
this franchise is a proud franchise that
has always been one of the uh you know
excellent franchises that always
consistently has a good team and john
elway whatever he's doing there he's run
out of the juice because his draft picks
haven't been working his quarterbacks
haven't been working and they are
sitting here right now waking up when
they thought maybe hey we'll go three
and four because patrick mahomes got
hurt with a lot of questions and big
questions in denver
over the last eight years i have now
done a 360 on the hiring of john elway
because i remember when the broncos
brought him in i said you're making a
mistake this guy hasn't been groomed to
be a gm he hasn't been a scout there's
no other team that is clamoring to hire
john elway to do anything it's just
because of the connection to the broncos
and they don't know what else to do so
let's bring in john elway well then he
lures peyton manning to town and i look
like an idiot when they win the super
bowl but big cat other than the peyton
manning move now he did draft von miller
third overall but i yeah it's not like
that was a reach um but other than the
peyton manning move at quarterback it's
been one mistake after another whether
it's a draft pick whether it's a veteran
that they trade for or that they sign
and to say that joe flacco was entering
his problem he was the only person i
agreed with you yeah everyone was saying
what the hell are they doing except for
john elway and if they had an actual
owner there in denver there's still a
three-person
group of trustees that runs the team and
i don't think anybody's going to fire
john elway until they hand the keys to
the franchise to one of pat bolin's
children he's got some immunity still
and you know the fans are just gonna
have to deal with it
yeah he's still john freaking elway i
mean that's that's the problem when you
hire your guy it's hard to fire your guy
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports